my name is Jeffrey back I'm from I work
at two sigma now I've had career working
at a number of different places I worked
I worked continuum for a little while
and I've been managing pandas since
about 2013 it's been it's been pretty
interesting I started off as a you know
an occasional committer or actually back
then it really wasn't even we didn't use
too much github it was just more like oh
there's like some issues you know github
was in its infancy back then and and
eventually I it's like a trade you know
you start trading the project and then
you start owning it so so you know I
start off my slide decks usually this
this is Wes McKinney he is the original
you know owner of the project he gets
all the kudos I get all the complaints
okay thank you all right so before we
talk about energy rent we're gonna talk
about the state of pandas and this will
lead you to see where we are
so the good about pandas then we're
going about the current state of pandas
hopefully we can turn into this that's a
happy panda if it doesn't look good
there yeah I mean pandas is is pretty
heavily used and but you know people are
starting to run into some of the limits
and we'll talk about that you know
during this talk alright so some of the
good things python is pretty popular
this is like a good thing this is you've
probably all seen this chart this is the
you know Stack Overflow questions that
have occurred over the last you know few
years and you can see you know Python
has an amazing trajectory here it could
also be that Python is just getting
harder or I think it's more that you
know we have a lot of newcomers to you
who are using the languages and of
course they have you know have questions
and stack overflow is now you know
pretty much the place to use these
there so one of the big drivers has been
the data science stack it used to be you
know you'd go to PyCon and you could
call it Django Khan but actually last
couple years have been really data
science at the forefront and this of
course has been driving a lot of the a
lot of the tooling you know things like
Conda and kind of Forge and of course a
lot of the packages that that anchor the
data science stack like like numpy and
matt positive and and in pandas and so
you see the popularity here you know I
don't know whether this is causal or not
but now I'll point out one thing which
is let's see if I can see my I don't
have a master I'll point well so I
started managing the project in 2012 so
so just an overview of where pandas like
where I view it sits but you know pandas
is essentially the user API for data
science you know you're you're bringing
in your data you know via pandas and in
fact probably the biggest success of
pandas has been the the CSV reader it
has brought a lot of you know people
their data in and done some minimal
cleaning on it and then of course what
you do is you you can dispatch the other
packages you know you know cycler and
then tensorflow and and all the fancy
packages out there or even you know play
sick Baines basic statistics like stats
models have been very very popular and
and used in any pandas just works you
know pretty well with them scikit-learn
actually just released a new version
which works you know it you know to
preserve your column labels which is
always nice and and of course you know
then you want to visualize your data and
so if you know pandas has some easy to
use dispatch management mechanisms to to
to matplotlib and things like that so
panda sort of sits at the the Nexus of
the whole data science stack and this
has been been been great actually means
you know pandas is used pretty heavily
so we've seen lots of you know feature
requests and enhancements and and bug
reports of course
so this leads me to the bad and the ugly
you know pandas has been it will say
showing its age
pandas has really been around since
about 2008 that's when it was originally
set up and of course back then what did
you do you always started with a 2d
numpy array of floats that's what you
did why because that was easy that's
what you had already but the landscape
is changing a lot now
most data you're getting from you know
maybe a remote data source or maybe
you're even reading it off this but
you're reading a certain smaller number
of columns they potentially have and
usually have multiple D types so it's a
little bit harder to manipulate this
data and especially as as things scale
and that's where people are starting to
hit hit you know limits we're not going
to talk about these warts and pandas
today but I'm just you know listing a
couple of things that that I
particularly find limiting you know
complex group eyes get hard to express
you know in some sense this is a
fundamental limitation of Python itself
we don't have macros but you know that's
just a an issue UDF's which is
user-defined functions they're very
opaque to pandas in other words
everybody's done a group I apply and
then it's slow and you wonder why well
because we can't delve down and the code
you're using now there's a lot of ways
to work to work around this and things
like that and of course the big problem
is copy semantics are very awkward in
pandas you we basically copy everything
the data frame is mostly immutable and
this causes memory blow-up so I have a
slide in a second about this but this
causes you know problems for performance
you know and this is of course when you
scale furthermore pandas is not really a
first-class citizen
in terms of the data science world when
we want to share data it's great winner
in Python but if you want to share with
like Julia or with our it's increasingly
become hard now there are some solutions
on the horizon you know pandas
integrates a lot a lot better nowadays
with pie arrow which does have
cross-language Interop so this is this
is definitely improving so this is the
the state of the world right now
you know pandas is fantastic really up
to like 10 gigs or something and you
know of course you can get really big
machines nowadays but it still becomes
hard so the question is is can pandas
change to accommodate some of these even
larger use cases and the answer is I
think we can do some things so one thing
that is happening is the the increasing
adoption we're using it more internally
of Pi era we're using it to read parque
we're also using it to do data
interchange this helps to unify the you
know pandas when it's used in in big
data type environments like spark things
like that but I think we can do even
more and this is the point of this talk
here today so I would say about six or
eight months ago there's a use case
which I'm going to go over where we need
well let me back up a little bit over
the years we've had numpy as our base
memory format and our D type system and
a few years ago this became relatively
limiting we wanted to do things like
have date times with time zones we want
to have categorical D types and this was
increasingly hard to do well we made
things work and it was just not it it
solved a lot of issues but it wasn't
general enough for it wasn't flexible
enough to handle even more things out
there our D types were you know ad hoc
every time we wanted to add something so
we started off with de times with time
zones and categoricals and we eventually
added some support for intervals and
some support for periods as first-class
types in data frames but they but there
were a lot of effort to implement these
there were a lot of work so Tom ox
Berger and and he defined the first
standard for this we call it extension
arrays this is a we'll call it an
interface specification for how to add
external
both d-types in memory formats and
computational structures actually two
pandas as a first-class citizen to be
able to do it in a way that's scalable
and I am it scalable in terms of
developer time really the ability to add
things without doing a whole lot of work
so that's what we did we now have a
format and we'll go through this in a
little bit giving the example of how we
added integer and a support to pandas so
this is basically two things
it's a D type so we have we'll call it
real data types
just like numpy has float 64's now we
have a real D type for for de times with
time zones we have a real D type for
categoricals it's actually
parameterizing and this allows one big
thing it allows a complete decoupling of
the storage format and how we deal with
it in pandas so no longer are we forced
to wrap things in numpy object arrays we
can actually have just an interface to
talk to some opaque object and so I'm
going to show a couple of use cases of
how this matters and what it gets for
you so when the 24 release comes out
which would be hopefully within a month
or so this has been a long - a long
release cycle maybe four or five months
already we're gonna have the types that
we had before day time with time zones
intervals categoricals and periods
except these are gonna be recast into
our new extension array types also we
just merged we have a first-class sparse
type now now this is an interesting you
can have a whole talk on sparse itself
pandas has a we'll call it a weird
sparse format that's sort of its own
and we may eventually adopt another
format but it's now a first-class type
and then of course we added integer any
support as a first-class type so here's
two little examples you know
categoricals in the left here where we
want to represent a type that has many
values but not so many uniques a lot of
folks use it nowadays to save memory
actually but this is a real thing if you
use statistics at all you
think of this as a factor type of and
then I'm gonna show an example also I'm
not gonna actually show categoricals but
I'm gonna show a real example of how to
do unit support and this has been a long
time also missing feature of really lots
of packages so external rates already
exist in the wild actually as they say
and I'm gonna go through this example in
a little bit
cyber pandas was the original motivating
use case for this followed closely by
geo pandas and these are two external
data types they're in separate repos
they really they have no dependents they
have the dependency on pandas but pandas
doesn't even know about these at all
doesn't care actually there's an effort
underway it's a little bit experimental
at this point it's called Fletcher
arrays it's actually backing a an
extension array with a PI error array
itself and this is an interesting
development for the future we're
watching it pretty closely it's done by
one of the PI or developers actually and
then I'm gonna go through an example of
a piont this is one of the unit
libraries I'm going to show you how to
do that I also listed decimal and JSON
support up top we actually implement
these in pandas so you get these sort of
for free so now you can have you can
hold decimals in your series very
cheaply actually and do operations on
them as if they're first-class objects
so let me just show you and then it'll
become clear so this is the repo all the
all the examples are here and let me go
to them let's see so this demo this this
talk is a lot of Show and Tell actually
pandas is one of these funny packages I
don't have any fancy like graphs for you
but I have a lot of show-and-tell let's
see okay
cannot zoom in a little bit here can you
see that okay so I'm just indicating
that this requires you know pandas
master at this point and this will be
released pretty soon in in pandas 24 so
pandas inner journey why do we actually
care about this you care because of this
so this is probably the bane of all
people where you have an integer series
that see that's in 64 and then it
suddenly turns into float64 that's a
little bit unnerving this is solely due
to the way we're storing these we can't
store integers or we don't have an NA
value for integers in fact I consider
doing this a few years ago actually
using a sentinel value similar to how we
do this for daytime 64's and it would
have worked actually this we never did
it but it's it's not super extensible to
do that you know doing this for n64 is
one thing but when you have int eight
what do you use as your Sentinel value I
can pick one but that may be a problem
problem in the real world so this is
just a better solution so what we can do
now is this so I think to note the D
type is actually a capitalized version
of the D type it's a little bit weird so
this is actually an opt-in extension and
it's so it's it's not going to break
your any existing code nothing will be
forced converted to this at some point
I'm gonna turn it on but not yet because
the problem is I haven't even turned on
pandas test suite and I know we're gonna
have like a thousand breaking tests if I
do that but the point is it is opt-in
for now you can use all your favorite in
types and UN types they just have a
capitalized letter it seems a little bit
like odd but that's sort of convenient
and and the point is it gives you a an
object underlying this and we're going
to show you how it looks and it
preserves it actually it prints out
Nan's just because you know people are
used to that but it preserves the ins so
you could do all kinds of your favorite
things with us you can do sums and you
get back scalars but you can hold it in
data frames and this is also you know
this is where it becomes pretty useful
so we create a data frame here
with two columns one so we're actually
holding a regular int column or a
regular pandas column and we're holding
a new extension or a column here they
look and feel very similar and that's
that's on purpose actually so you can do
lots of things with these you can group
by them actually here we're grouping by
the int column and then we're going to
sum and create the sum of the extension
or a column and we have you know regular
this is just a regular grouping
operation I haven't done anything
special here we get back a regular group
index I'm gonna show the comparison in a
second but is in my right here there's a
bug here I just filed an issue on the
tracker for it the issue is that this
return type should actually be in 64
here with a capital I okay
so there's still bugs in this this is
another reason not to release this in
the wild is like a fully baked feature
and they're very subtle sometimes you
know the protocols inside pandas are not
all updated we haven't hit all the
education yet so that's that's you know
part of the reason for putting this as
an optional add-on feature so that's
that's the bug so but there's also some
other limitations so if I do the reverse
operation where I group by the extension
array and into column and do the sum I
actually get back this object index it's
kind of weird because remember when you
group by something you get the index of
the grouper as your you get the values
of the index that are the uniques as
your index and this is alright now a
limitation we don't actually have an
extension array index itself there's a
PR up to put one in but we just don't
have it yet so there's a lot of features
of pandas which we need to build out to
really fully accept extension raises as
first-class citizens
but here is the what everybody wants
right you know we have our data frame we
add one to it and we preserve D types
okay that's great
but more interestingly now is we're
gonna assign some Nan's
and if you look at I just assign a nan
to the second column here or the the the
the second row road
- oh sorry and then I do a fill an a and
we have preservation of D types and you
know this is something that you would
expect would just work unfortunately
with our implementation of numpy tea
types it doesn't work for regular
columns for for for regular int so we
have force conversion here it preserves
it okay
indexing works exactly as you expect so
interesting enough extension raiser
don't even care about this too much they
just need really simple indexing so most
operations are simply preserved now how
do we actually implement this array well
it's actually really simple so take our
series it's just so we have these
first-class types and they're called
arrays in some sense these are drop-in
replacements for numpy arrays that's the
goal actually they may not be full drop
ins we're not gonna support the full
panoply of methods that numpy raise do
they have way too many methods but for
the most part they'll just simply work
okay and the implementation actually is
really simple it's just data and it's
actually a number two numpy race is what
it is it's a mask and the data itself
that's actually interesting that if i
fill it with ones of all things so but
the point here is the implementations
complete separate from the interface you
could actually do whatever you want here
in fact one thing I think I'm gonna do
this is actually this mask here is
actually a numpy array of it's a boolean
array but it's actually takes up a
little bit of space we could actually
represent this as a bit array we don't
actually need a full byte array but okay
it works fine for now and it and it
doesn't add a huge amount of overhead
but this leads to an interesting
question how does this fundamentally
change your view of data frames and and
I had some conversations earlier today
about this
so long story short and this is not a
discussion of data frame internals but
pandas stores most data as
two-dimensional arrays so you think that
that seems natural right we have you
know D type so we store a list of
two-dimensional arrays and that seems ok
at the outset until you start doing
things like modifying part of those
arrays or splitting them apart pandas we
call this the block manager and this has
been a longtime feature of pandas it was
it was set up originally in 2008 and it
works fantastic when you start with st.
umpire raise to D numpy arrays and you
put them into pandas constructor there
zero copy it's great but then when you
start mixing in other D types and
changing things it's not so great you
end up with lots and lots of copies so
how does extension raise differ in this
well differs in a fundamental way here
so I'm creating another data frame here
I'm adding two more columns another in
column and another integer and a column
ignore the warning
I'm just forcing what's called a
consolidation here I'm forcing the block
manatee to do its thing it's kind of
lazy on doing this anyway so I'm just
forcing something that should happen
later and not to go too much in the
internals but what you'll notice here is
the float block here has been what's
called consolidated so we've taken those
two 1d float arrays and we've copied
them into another one a 2d one but the
extent arrays we haven't done anything
with so we haven't copied these we've in
fact taking the original arrays and left
them like they are so this actually
offers quite a number of performance
advantages in the fact that we it's not
that we don't copy them we defer the
copying to the extension area itself so
you can choose to copy you could use
views you have a lot of power there but
with regular scalars like with regular
numpy d types we don't offer that
possibility we may at some point but not
yet so the interface that we've defined
is actually pretty simple it looks
almost like a series you know we have
things like drop and then we have we
have this routine called factorise which
is basically
mapping things to numbers we use this in
grouping and all kinds of things so we
have a number of routines which you must
define like take some basic indexing
operations things like is something an
NA and unique
once you define these you instantly have
an extension array so it's pretty pretty
easy to do actually and I'm gonna show
you an example of someone who did it
without any interference with from us at
all which is kind of neat well this
should be in the next site but what
doesn't work well a lot the two bugs
I've pointed out already but one more so
you can of course take your data frame
and write it to a CSV I'm writing it to
a string in this case but reading it
back is just I guess the errors off off
the charts here but it just doesn't work
yet and then you know this will be fixed
it's it's more of a matter of not
everything works right now serializing
these two other formats doesn't work yet
but it will there's always been there's
already been some effort as an example
to make this work with tasks you know
things like and we support you know hash
ability of data frames and that like
already works all right I'm gonna show
you two more examples here so this is
the original motivating example the top
here for y extension ways arrays were
created this is also a public library
called cyber pandas say ever you want to
store IP addresses and I don't know I'm
sure there's people who you know network
people who want to do this it's a pretty
useful thing but let me show you why
it's useful well once you have an array
this is a fully first-class array type
you can define your own methods on it
and you know to do various you know
kinds of operations which are endemic to
that type you've really typed specific
stuff you also have the opportunity to
define your own scalars now in my
previous example of pandas you know with
integer na my scaler was a numpy scaler
it was actually it could be a nut my
scalar or could be a Python scaler I
didn't have to define a scalar in this
case I do want to define a scalar
because I want it to be imbued with a
certain properties as well and then of
course you can put these in series and
here's another interesting thing that's
not interesting
here's here's the interesting thing so
everybody is seeing what we call
accessors things like when we do dot DT
or dot cat or not STR these are methods
which are type specific so it will only
work on that type strings or
categoricals or de times so you could do
this as well you can define a method
that will only show up on your type
really pretty useful you get tab
completion see if I can actually do that
here hmm sure and then of course you can
put these with other types just as a
week just as we saw before so these
types are really our first class let me
show you one final example here so this
is a library I only found out about
because someone pinged me on their repo
this was piont this is a I don't know if
you say it's pintor maybe piont I'm not
sure this is one of the we'll call it
three different libraries for units out
there there's one called quantity and
there's another one called I think ype
int or something like that these are
actually used a lot by the astronomy
folks but there's obviously a lot a ton
of other people who want to do this now
why do units matter you know units are a
big deal because you know we'll go back
to the simple physics force equals mass
times acceleration right and if I don't
know which column is which you might get
confused you might lose the labels so to
speak so we can of course label things I
mean think about what pandas does
fundamentally it takes a numpy array and
slaps labels on there this goes even one
step further and adds a piece of
metadata that's carried around on the
labeled
that also knows how to do operations
with other units of that type or not
necessary of that type now we already
have some features like this in pandas
itself example when you take a time
Delta and you multiply by two well we
know how to do it but we don't have real
first class made a data propagation we
have some mechanisms for it but this
adds it in the first class way and this
was done completely in an external
library you need also a master of piont
it may be released by now I don't know
you need master of pandas but soon both
of these will be public so example you
have some data and you've labeled what
kind of Yunnan it is and here we
actually see so we're reading it into a
CSV and then we're actually using some
will call it accessors that are actually
defined on the data frame itself to
basically turn these into you notice the
labels disappeared and we'll see them
reappear in a second these now know what
units they are so these are all piont
types and of course you can do
operations on these now the operations
are solely determined by the type itself
it may raise in certain cases maybe it's
wrong maybe these things are not
implemented yet but the point is the
type is solely and control the
operations here pandas doesn't know
anything about this we simply defer the
operations to the type so here you know
we're defining a new type and it knows
how to do this this calculation here and
a similar type of this is they decided
to implement a conversion type and you
can convert to kilowatts here kilowatts
here and then get them nice pretty
printing here I don't know if you can
see that too well and of course you know
I don't know what that slide was okay so
again the implementation is a custom
type and a custom array and that's it so
you can define these these are base
classes in pandas and you can go and
create your own they say there's there's
quite a number out there already I
expect
you know more to be created because
these are really are useful in they're
very very lightweight I think at some
point we might actually completely take
out all of our numpy back types and
replace them with extension arrays maybe
we'll see some enterprising person wants
to come into this would be great let's
see go back I think that's my that's
life so so these are the three eccentric
times I did here and I will be I'll
tweet these out at some point later so
that's it any questions thank you
great talk um quick question you
mentioned to deferred copies they're
like a copy on bright idea or did I get
that wrong it's not that it's a copy on
right idea it's when I say so if I have
a series and I need to copy it okay
you'll get a copy call in the in the
interface you could actually do
something like take a view and you can
defer your own copy to when you have set
item call on you as an example so the
ability to do copy and write is possible
now but it's deferred to the extension
right now no one's implemented this but
it's possible he melts
Sabine's okay so the question was what
about accentuates four strings so right
now we have extension to raise four
categoricals and you can use them for
Strings however there's some limitations
because the fact that they are
categoricals they fall categorical
semantics okay so the answer is yes
there's a string type coming and that
will be a think of it as almost a light
wrapping of categoricals when we remove
the restrictions okay so we'll just
automatically categories things will
allow you to add strings to that set
without blowing up okay so the answer is
not very hard to do that
there was also even a request I heard
from someone else to do fixed length
strings all of these things are possible
and not a whole lot of work and they can
be done in an external library if they
were super useful certainly we could you
know consider bringing them into pandas
proper itself Jeff how do the integer
arrays differ from like a massive array
they look very similar so from the
external viewpoint as they look again
look very similar just as just as pandas
internals look similar to a masquerade
the answer is they so if you're asking
could mask arrays be used as an
implementation Ezard yes do they differ
no not significantly but they play nice
with data frames that's that's that's
the main use case to be very honest any
other questions
all right that's it if you have any more
questions I'll be outside thank you so
much Jeff everybody give him a round a
frog
[Applause]